hello everybody and welcome to this tutorial on
a new opportunity to come and work for the EU
institutions we have just published a competition
to select experts in the field of intellectual
property and as usual on our website you will
find this visual giving you an overview of the
different steps to take to become a successful
candidate in this competition in this tutorial
I will walk you through these different steps
and tell you what the details are of each phase
the eligibility criteria it is an 86th
grade competition meaning you need either
a bachelor degree in law plus three years of
experience in the field of intellectual property
or a bachelor in other field than Law
plus five years of relevant experience
or a bachelor in an other field in Law plus four
years of experience and an additional master or
PhD in intellectual property rights you will find
this of course Very detently explained in the
notice of competition which you find also on the
website where we have published this competition
then there's also of course a language Criterium
you need to speak two different EU languages your
language one can be any of the 24 and you
must Master it on level C1 and your left
your language two should be one of five either
English French German Italian or Spanish because
these five languages are the languages used in
the office dealing with intellectual properties
which is by the by the way based in Alicante so a
nice destination and a nice place of work if ever
you are successful in this competition your
language too should be at least at level B2
the selection procedure looks at this it has
roughly three stages if you like first there's
an application Phase then there's a testing phase
and then there's of course the results phase
everybody who applies gets invited to a single day
of testing so in one day you will sit the three
tests listed here reasoning skills feed the rater
test and the case study I will get into detail a
bit later in this tutorial you will sit all these
tests remotely so you do not have to travel to a
test center to take these tests you can simply
sit them from your home computer at your ease
the third phase is then of course the results uh
phase so let's get into detail um in these three
phases everything starts with an application and
in order to apply you need to create an episode
account of course if you already have an episode
account you can use it to take part in this
competition or to apply for it if not you apply
you you create an account on our episode website
you can apply in any of the 24 languages
and you should do so before the 29th of
August noon Brussels time so you have plenty
of time to fill out your application form
I said everybody who applies gets invited to
book a testing date and on this day you will sit
several tests we start with testing your reasoning
skills we test your verbal numerical and abstract
reasoning skills in your language one you see the
questions and duration the scoring mentioned here
for the verbal reasoning test there is
a pass score of 10 out of 20 so you need
at least 10 out of 20. if you have more
very good if you do not have at least 10
out of 20 you are out of the opportunity
to be a successful candidate of course
for numerical and abstract reasoning there is
a combined passcore as you can see you need 10
out of 20 combined for these two tests you can
prepare for this uh reasoning skills test by
having a look to our sample tests which you find
on our website you see the link here and you find
sample tests in all 24 languages available to try
and prepare you for this test the second test you
will take is a field related test so there we will
assess your knowledge in the field of intellectual
property you will take this test in your second
language and the passcore is 15 out of 30 at least
the third test is a case study where we will
test your drafting skills in again your second
language the minimum pass score being 5
out of 10. now to calculate the final score
for you to know if you are on the list list
of successors candidates or not there is some
higher mathematics involved as you can see
on this slide but I will explain it to you
we take into account your score of the field
related test and the case studies or not the
reasoning skills test you need to meet the
pass score for the reason skills test as
long as you have met that passcore you are still
in the running for a place on the reserve list
the field rated test and the case study come into
play when ranking you when it comes to ranking you
for determining the list of successful candidates
the weight of the field rated test is 70 of the
final score and the weight of the case study score
is 30 so in the last column there you see that the
final score for the field rated test a is 70 of
your score that you reached when sitting the test
for the case study the final score B is
30 of your score obtained during the case
study test we multiply this score by three why
because the case study was marked on 10 points
and the feed rate test was marked on 30
points so if we first have to level this
out in order to be able to wait the scores
correctly to then reach a final score for
your results I hope that is clear it's all
explained again in the notice of competition
so the ones with the highest scores are the ones
listed on this so-called Reserve list or list of
successful candidates we are looking to select 200
successful candidates so again this is a very big
competition the ones listed on this on this list
are then recruitable by the EU IPO which is the EU
intellectual property office as I said based in
Alicante whenever they have vacancies available
they will scan the list invite the people to a job
interview and then if your your job interview is
successful you can start working in the office I
hope this is clear if not anyhow please do read
the notice of competition very carefully because
everything is very well explained in that document
and if you have more questions you can
always reach out to us through the web
form on our website my colleagues will be
very happy to answer all questions available
I wish you all good luck with applying and then
taking part in the tests of this competition and
I hope you'll be one of our future colleagues
in the EU thank you and see you next time